When I retired from boxing,
I really don't know.
I want to say something right here.
You all might.
This might make you all thing.
Life is not really long.
Let's say the average person,
30 years old,
if you're 30 years old,
you and not been about seven years old,
I cannot prove it.
Had above the seven,
eight,
nine hours.
You slept for 30 years out of 30 years
out of bothered the last night when you
went to bed and woke up this morning and
you don't remember a thing.
You've built a conscience about eight
years.
If you're 30 years old,
you strap at eight years.
Okay.
How much traveling have you done it?
Thirty years.
The television station to home to
another country,
to another city,
to school,
to church.
You've probably traveled two years in
life was spent just getting back and
forth to where you're going.
So there's eight years of sleeping,
two years of traveling.
That's 30 years out.
He liked before you're accomplishing the
thing.
How long do you sit in school?
In America,
we stayed in school from the twelfth
grade,
so from first grade to twelfth grade.
Same here,
virtually it's six hours a day,
six hours a day for 12 years.
Break it down.
You sit in the classroom for three years
without leaving.
Okay.
Two years of traveling,
eight years of sleeping.
Fie years of school.
How many moons right you went to?
How much?
How many movie theaters?
Live plays,
baseball games.
Probably two years of entertainment.
So by the town of Man,
you older people bear witness to what
I'm saying,
but the time you have children,
by the time you have made a way for your
children,
for the time you've paid for your home,
you pushing 60 years old.
Life is real short.
So yeah,
Paul,
you're traveling at a ball.
You sleeping at a school,
at a ball unit team,
you probably been half your life doing
that and so what am I out?
I'm 35 years old.
Thirty more years.
I'll be 65.
We don't have no more influence.
We can't do nothing.
Much of 65 wife will tell you that when
you're 65,
when you're 65,
eight.
Too much more to do.
So I'll be 65 and 30 more years in those
30 years after sleep.
Nine years.
I don't have 30 years of daylight after
travel back in America,
take six,
seven miles.
All my traveling probably four years of
traveling.
Next 30 years.
About nine years of sleeping television,
movies,
and the pain.
About three years of entertainment out
of 30 years.
I might have about 16 years.
So it's how we can all break
individualize them.